và công văn ở bán dân thành phố yêu cầu các đường bị lên quan thật két đầy đủ
đúng đối tượng các chính sách hỗ trợ học sinh người học đã được chú hương và hỗ đường như rất thành phố văn hành
các chính sách gồm hỗ trợ học phi được với trẻ em em non học sinh phổ thông
hỗ trợ gạo lối dụng cả nhân và học phòng trọng sinh trường phổ thông dân tập lỗi chú
hỗ trợ buãn bản chú đối thông sinh tiểu học theo quy định
kể hoạt phải sáng lịch lộ trình, phương an phân kỳ theo tự ngâm học, tựng các học, đối tượng
văn phố văn hành phố văn hành phố văn hành phố văn hành phố văn hành phố
xem sách, phê dụi trọng thông thông thông thông năm hành hành hình
dụi trọng mám sấu, sử dụng của đào tạo, có chế nghiệm xa lịch vụ cầu xử dụt
hiện trạng xấu xe gạo phóa hệt có, con xử dụt được và dụt kẹn phí phí cho tình có học
năm học, làm căn cứ xây dụt giữ trọng kinh phí hằng năm, thăm yêu văn dơ thành phố
có định việc tổ trích một sám tập trung hoặc phân cấp trọng sử dụt và đào tạo
quy bán dân phường xã, cơ sử dụt tự kẹn mô sám trích gạo qua, theo quy định của pháp lột về đổ thông
mấy cạnh đó sử dụt và đào tạo hướng dẫn trên lôn về câu trế mượt trả
của anh li xa gạo qua là tài sản công và điều trình đến thông thư biet